I'll never forget this girl and my condo
she was like hot and it would be like as
soon as she was in the studio all of us
trying to kick each other's [ __ ]
heads off because they were trying it
just being like we'd spar like
friendships are all break apart it's
like oh we're not friends I just wanna
look yeah yeah yeah and I'll never
forget I know you hear sometimes you
just get it and she just goes I know
what cuz we there was like a like a tent
there were other people there there was
a test the belt she goes oh yes I'm like
you're training like one of the guys and
you're acting like me guys I and I could
never take it on again get over my date
a girl like that I would tell you like
dude how about she did ah man y'all date
knives dating this girl I mean this is
years and years ago she blew up my
bathroom so bad came out and I she was
in there for a while as all and she
jumped in my bed my bathroom was at the
time was the one-bedroom small apartment
so the bathrooms right next to the bath
she blows it up it sounds like a goddamn
symphony in that bathroom she knows I'm
not sleeping I will [ __ ] no [ __ ] it's
not a wonder it's 9 o'clock now she was
like ooh know what shoes who kind of
trots in the bath I'm like well whatever
I'm still watching just TV she knows all
right there doesn't try to mask it or
anything yucky you like flush to it and
then rip it and then hopefully the sound
like Hoth is a silencer huh I'm gonna do
that yeah scene comes out and goes oh
Jesus man like no no that's a huge
problem has a god I went if I were a
girl I'm going I'll go outside I'll be
like I left something in my car I'll
[ __ ] on the side of the road before
yeah I'll hike with the earthen [ __ ]
elsewhere I did this I one time I was in
New York City and the girl was in my it
went it's a one-bedroom apartment Elia
the girl was sleeping in the bedroom I
was like the bathrooms too close she's
gonna to hear me take a [ __ ] nothing
worse I go into the [ __ ] kitchen
I take a plastic bag and take a dump
right in that plastic bag tie it up
smelled off-mic I tied that thing up ran
out to the trash chute and threw it out
and I was like that's how you I'm
writing up I remember well people who
are respectable citizens don't listen to
my podcast do not know don't do it
you'll hate earnest don't don't do it
agree if you have any respect for us
don't listen I don't know I just you
know sometimes with hotels I'm like dude
what dude does not what to hate or
design this first of all it's a glass
it's a [ __ ] glass toilet next to the
bed dude that's annoying
it's right there how the [ __ ] are we
gonna I can't share go lobby the lobby
gotta go to lobby I'm not taking this
[ __ ] there
I had one Domeier girl I was like um I
was I was going like I was washing my
face so you heard you always wash I
always watch it's so wet she goes like
this she goes he's clean I keep my
whistle would I keep my wife's clean bra
use wipe off you know that's a better
point they do have wifey's that you
could flush I use I do you I use white
bees and down it makes sure my shredders
only hold on let me tell what this grown
51 year old man chetu he gets on the
sink like a gargoyle it's not good this
dick and peace out the front and I see
him splash water up his [ __ ]
I've seen that I'm not Admiral I don't
know 70 times I'm not admitting that I
washed my ass in the sink I've seen it
happen many of times I don't get why you
just don't get a bidet III want a bad
day but it's you have to install it so
I'll just myself you can just get the
the you basically just buy the lid that
fit your toilet and all the what just
can't have a dirty whistle I can't have
a dirty whistle no matter what I have to
I get in the shower whatever I do I
clean my whistle my whistles clean early
I was just in case
just [ __ ] and kills that rub pole I
don't know why I just feel dirty if I
don't if I refused to wear a light
underwear all blacks camos you're a lazy
wiper huh
just defense them general rush dude
you'll [ __ ] on a [ __ ] public John
without putting any toilet paper down
either you
you know you guys think about the other
day I was on the toilet in Atlantic City
in the hotel okay and I was in the lobby
I'm like there's a lot of about a
thousand one thousand people have sat on
that tour mutants that are playing the
slot machines with one thousand seven
arms ten thousand shets they've been
sipping [ __ ] peanut claws just
[ __ ] all over this yeah here's what
you don't think of you think of your ass
every dude tucked his dick onto the
toilet
think how many tips of dicks have rested
on there and you have nowhere else but
you do well she don't touch that part
will you just hold it I hold it - it's
too much work
I will never let the head of my dick
that is the worst thing for me if I like
you know the inside of the bowl and the
head of your thing okay man I'm very
squeamish about about other how about
last night at the store right I'm in the
bathroom in a green room
yeah and I'm taking a peanut bat I'm
taking a piss and robots in and I come
right when he's like I think he's
washing his face like his head he's
doing something throwing something away
okay yeah and I'm coming out I have see
you just got done handling my goddamn
big Johnson yeah this giant dick right
just got don't do that with you like I
come out and without it without a beat
doesn't mean you know most people like
you wash your hands I mean [ __ ] meet
him just [ __ ] like it was [ __ ]
commando-style
yeah I don't that's all I purposely
don't wash my hel meter and I pray
somebody's never do it say some I did
that the other day it's my dick shooting
one of the crew guys I take a piss I
walk out because you don't want your
hands I go I don't [ __ ] wash my hands
if I repeat
absolutely not no if anything I'll wash
my hands before I touch my dick me too
or I'll wash my hands when I walk
outside the bathrooms I touched the
handle I heard somebody say I don't know
if it's true I heard somebody say you
can get warts on your dick if you've
been shaking a lot of hands and ever
since I heard that I get paranoid I'm
like what it's not looks gross that's
[ __ ] right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business